is there a species that's the Apex
intelligence right now on Earth
so it's not trivial to say that humans
are that yeah it's not trivial I agree
it's a you know I think one of the
things that I I've long been curious
about kind of other intelligences so to
speak
um I mean I you know I I view
intelligence is like computation and
it's kind of a you know you're sort of
you have the set of rules you deduce
what happens
um I have tended to think now that
there's this kind of specialization of
computation that is sort of a
consciousness-like thing that has to do
with these you know computational
boundedness single thread of experience
these kinds of things that are the
specialization of computation that
corresponds to a somewhat human-like
experience of the world now the question
is so so that's you know there may be
other intelligences like you know you
know the aphorism you know the weather
has a mind of its own it's a different
kind of intelligence that can compute
all kinds of things that are hard for us
to compute but it is not well aligned
with us with the way that we think about
things it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't
think the way we think about things and
you know in this idea of different
different intelligences every different
mind every different human mind is a
different intelligence that thinks about
things in different ways and you know in
in terms of the kind of formalism of our
physics project we talk about this idea
of rule space the space of all possible
sort of rule systems and different minds
are in a sense of different points in
real space human Minds ones that have
grown up with the same kind of culture
and ideas and things like this might be
pretty close in real space pretty easy
for them to communicate pretty easy to
translate pretty easy to move from one
place in rural space that corresponds to
one mind to another place in real space
that corresponds to another sort of
nearby mind when we deal with kind of
more distant things in rural space like
you know the the pet cat or something
you know the pet cat has some aspects
that are shared with us the emotional
responses of the cat are somewhat
similar to ours but the cat is further
away in real space than people are and
so then the question is you know can we
identify sort of the can we make a
translation from our thought processes
to the thought processes of a cat or
something like this and you know what
what will we get when we you know what
what will happen when we get there and I
think it's the case that that many you
know many animals I don't know dogs for
example you know they have a labrador
Factory systems they you know they they
have sort of the smell architecture of
the of the of the world so to speak in a
way that we don't and so you know if if
you were sort of talking to the dog and
you could you know communicate in a
language the dog will say well this is a
you know a a you know a flowing smelling
this that and the other thing Concepts
that we just don't have any idea about
now what's what's interesting about that
is one day we will have chemical sensors
that do a really pretty good job you
know we'll have artificial noses that
work pretty well and we might have our
augmented reality system show us kind of
the same map that the dog could see and
things like this so that you know
similar to what happens in the dog's
brain and eventually we will have kind
of expanded in real space to the point
where we will have those same sensory
experiences that dogs have and we will
have internalized what it means to have
you know the smell landscape or whatever
and and so then we will have kind of
colonized that part of Royal space
um until you know we haven't gone you
know some things that that you know
animals and so on do we've sort of
successfully understand others we do not
and the question of of what kind of what
is the uh you know what what
representation you know how how do we
convert things that animals think about
to things that we can think about that's
not a trivial thing
um and you know I've I've long been
curious I had a very bizarre project at
one point of of trying to make an iPad
game that a cat could win against its
owner right it feels like there's a deep
philosophical
go there though yes yes I mean the the
you know I was curious if you know if
pets can work in Minecraft or something
and can construct things what will they
construct and will what they construct
be something where we look at and we say
yeah I recognize that or will it be
something that looks to us like
something that's out there in the
computational universe that one of my
you know cellular automata might have
produced where we sell yeah I can kind
of see it operates got into some rules I
don't know why you would use those rules
I don't know why you would care yeah I
uh actually it's just a link on that
seriously is there a connector in the
Royal space between you and a cat
well the cat could legitimately win so
iPad is a very limited um interface yeah
I wonder if there's a game where cats
win I think the problem is the cats
don't tend to be that interested in
what's happening on the iPad yeah it
doesn't interface issue probably yeah
right right right no I I think it is
likely that I mean you know there are
plenty of animals that would
successfully eat us if we were you know
if we were exposed to them and so
there's you know it it's going to pounce
faster than we can get out of the way
and so on so there are plenty of and and
probably it's going to you know we think
we've hidden ourselves but we haven't
successfully hidden ourselves that's a
physical strength I wonder if there's uh
something in more in the realm of uh
intelligence where an animal like a cat
well I think there are things certainly
in terms of the the speed of processing
certain kinds of things for sure I mean
the the question of what you know is
there a game of chess for example is
there cat chess yeah that the cats could
play against each other and if we tried
to play a cat we don't always lose I
don't know you might have to do a speed
but it might have to do with Concepts
also there might be Concepts in the
cat's head I I tend to think that our
species from its invention of language
has managed to build up this kind of
tower of abstraction that for things
like a chess-like game will make us win
in other words we've become through the
fact that we've kind of experienced
language and learned abstraction you
know we've sort of become smarter at
those kinds of abstract kinds of things
now you know that doesn't make us
smarter at catching a mouse or something
it makes us smarter at the things that
we've chosen to to sort of con you know
concern ourselves which are these kind
of abstract things yeah and I think you
know this is again back to the question
of of you know what does one care about
you know if one's a if one's the you
know the cat if you if you have the
discussion with a cat if we can if we
can translate things to have the
discussion with a cat the cat will say I
you know I'm very excited that uh this
light
is moving and we'll say why do you care
and the cat will say that's the most
important thing in the world yeah that
this thing moves around I mean it's like
when you ask about I don't know you you
look at archaeological remains and you
say these people had this you know
belief system about this and you know
that was the most important thing in the
world to them
um and and now we look at it and say we
don't know what the point is but it was
I mean I I've been curious you know that
these hand prints on caves from 20 000
or more years ago and it's like nobody
knows what these handprints were there
for you know that they may have been a
representation of the most important
thing you can imagine they may just have
been some you know some kid who who
rubbed their hands in the mud and stuck
them on the walls of the cave you know
we don't we don't know and I think but
this this whole question of what
um you know is
when you say uh this question of sort of
what's the smartest thing around there's
the question of what kind of computation
are you trying to do if you're saying
you know if you say you've got some
well-defined computation and how do you
implement it well you could implement it
by nerve cells you know firing you can
implement it with silicon and
electronics you can implement it by some
kind of molecular computation process in
the human immune system or in some
molecular biology kind of thing they're
different ways to implement it and you
know I think this question of of uh of
sort of which you know those different
implementation methods will be of
different speeds they'll be able to do
different things if you say uh you know
which so an interesting question would
be
um
what kinds of abstractions are most
natural in these different kinds of
systems so for a cat it's for example
you know the visual scene that we see
you might you know we pick out certain
objects we recognize you know certain
things in that visual scene a cat might
in principle recognize different things
I I suspect you know Evolution
biological evolution is very slow and I
suspect what a cat notices is very
similar we even know that from some
neurophysiology what a catnosis is is
very similar to what we notice of course
there's a you know one obvious
differences cats have only two kinds of
color receptors so they don't see in the
same kind of color that we do now you
know we say we're we're better we have
three color receptors you know red green
blue we're not the overall winner I
think the the I think the mantis shrimp
is the overall winner winner with 15
color receptors I think so it can it can
kind of make distinctions that with our
current you know like the Mantis
shrimp's view of reality is inside at
least in terms of color is much richer
than ours
um now but what's interesting is how do
we get there so imagine we have this
augmented reality system that is even
you know it's singing into the infrared
into the ultraviolet things like this
and it's Translating that into something
that is connectable to our brains either
through our eyes or more directly into
our brains
um you know then eventually our kind of
web of the types of things we understand
will extend to those kinds of constructs
just as they have extended I mean there
are plenty of things where we see them
in the modern world because we made them
with technology and now we understand
what that is but if we'd never seen that
kind of thing we wouldn't have a way to
describe it we wouldn't have a way to
understand it and so on